[Music]
an ancient creature is lurking in the
ocean
it's double the size of a T-Rex
its gigantic Jaws could crush a car and
now it's on the hunt for you
Megalodon sharks haven't existed for
more than two million years but today
we're bringing these apex predators back
to wreak some havoc
now some people believe Megs never went
extinct instead they're hiding in the
deepest depths of our oceans
the Mariana Trench
well if the Megalodons were still around
that would be the last place you'd find
them
that's because these prehistoric tyrants
hated cold water
they preferred the warmer Waters of the
Mediterranean and the Caribbean
they also loved to explore the coasts of
Australia and California
if these Predators were around today
they might seriously ruin your Beach
vacation
but if they spotted you swimming in the
ocean
they wouldn't just attack right away and
this has to do with your size
Megalodon sharks were gigantic
at least 16 meters in length so they
needed a lot of food
scientists estimate that Megs ate about
1200 kilograms of fish every day
to hit their caloric intake goals they
even dined on sea mammals like whales
and dolphins
so you puny human might not be worth
their attention
unless you were hanging out with a group
of friends now that's a worthier snack
and the Megalodon could devour you and
your friends all in one bite
oh and let me tell you these Predators
had gigantic sharp teeth
each one of the Megalodon's teeth was as
big as your hand and unlike us humans
Megs kept producing new sets of teeth
every week or two in their lifetime
they'd go through up to 40 000 of them
if they never went extinct you could
find those all over the ocean
you could find some huge carcasses too
but that wouldn't happen all too often
scientists think that megalodons had a
lifespan of up to 100 years
but you know even if humans weren't on
the Megalodons menu their enormous
appetite would hurt us in other ways
with this huge new predator in the
oceans there'd barely be any fish left
for us
and not because their boats wouldn't
catch anything but because they would
and then megalodons would hunt them down
attack and eat everything in sight
it's not clear why megalodons
disappeared these millions of years ago
but it could be because the oceans got
too cold for them well now they'd be in
for a treat because our oceans are
warming up
thanks climate change
megalodons would Thrive and reproduce
you'd see more and more of these
Predators showing up
they'd be disrupting our shipping
operations and potentially bringing an
end to the cruise industry
but eventually they might die out once
again after they ate whatever they could
in the ocean and had nothing more to
feed on
welcome to Jurassic world in real life
let's bring back some of the most
dangerous creatures to ever roam the
Earth
what could go wrong
right
how would we be able to clone dinosaurs
What would life with them roaming the
Earth be like
and which ones would eat you for
breakfast first
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we brought dinosaurs back from
Extinction
in the book and the subsequent movie
Saga of Jurassic Park
scientists find DNA from dinosaur blood
preserved inside of a fossilized
mosquito
then they clone a whole theme Park's
worth of prehistoric creatures
and of course all hell breaks loose what
you might not know is that the story was
inspired by real life events
in 1982 scientists discovered a 40
million year old fly mummified in Amber
and that's where the non-fiction drama
ends and author Michael crichton's
science fiction begins
but it's not the only discovery that has
raised the question of whether you could
bring dinosaurs back from Extinction
components of dinosaur blood were
discovered in a fossilized mosquito from
the eocene Epic
but there wasn't any dinosaur DNA that
we could use for cloning
DNA is a vulnerable thing it could be
deteriorated by sunlight or water
so far the oldest DNA discovered is one
million years old
so if you want to clone dinosaurs you'd
need to find DNA at least 66 times older
than that
instead of waiting on the miraculous
discovery of dinosaur DNA let's try
something different
like genetically reverse engineering
dinosaurs
take an animal that's alive today and
work backward
okay so going back through 66 million
years of evolution wouldn't be a walk in
the park genetically engineering a
chicken to have teeth or a long tail
wouldn't exactly make it a dinosaur
life uh
finds a way
now if your dinosaur Creations somehow
escaped your maximum security lab and
began living in the wild
you should be ready for trouble
with over 700 different dinosaur species
discovered worldwide
you'd have to find out which of them
would be safest to share the planet with
and which ones would pose a serious
threat
and you'd have to figure that out the
hard way
they would breed on their own they'd be
hunted for sport or for meat maybe even
kept as pets and then there would be a
tyrannosaurus rex on the prowl for you
well no not specifically you humans in
general people would spend less time
Outdoors out of fear of velociraptor
attacks
jobs requiring travel would become
infinitely more dangerous
do you want to be driving an 18-wheeler
with one of these things running across
the highway
travel would also be more expensive
because of extra security precautions
delays and cancellations would be common
due to the flight patterns of
pterodactyls and food supply Chains
would be disrupted as cattle and other
livestock would be prime targets for
predatory dinosaurs
these creatures never had mammals to
snack on in the past
ranches and Farms would be like a buffet
for them
massive herbivores like sauropods would
struggle to meet their dietary needs
the plants that currently exists
wouldn't be the same as those millions
of years ago
sauropods wouldn't have teeth Jaws or
digestive systems adapted to eating the
grasses that are common today
other animals and living things would
need to adapt to the new Predators on
the Block
dinosaurs would be the ultimate invasive
species and their presence could cause
Extinction events for some of today's
species it wouldn't be a bed of roses
for the dinosaurs either unless they
were engineers to be adapted to our
modern day Global environments and
climate they would struggle too
during the Cretaceous Period the
atmosphere had 14 percent more oxygen
than ours does today for dinosaurs it
would feel like they were suddenly
living at a Mount Everest Base Camp
if you could bring dinosaurs back you'd
be facing a major ethical dilemma
Mother Nature wiped them out
reintroducing them for pure
entertainment would be a hard case to
win against scientists pushing for
further conservation efforts especially
if you're planning to open your very own
Jurassic Park lots of people would want
to enjoy the dinosaurs in a zoo-like
setting
you could stand to make a lot of money
could a monster be lurking in our oceans
and no we're not talking about the Loch
Ness monster or the Megalodon we're
talking about a creature you've probably
never heard of
the mosasaur
but what's a mosasaur
could the Mosasaur have survived the
great Extinction and if it did how would
it change our oceans
this is what if and here's what would
happen if mosasaurus were still alive
in 2014 a British tourist spotted a
strange creature while on a cruise ship
in the Gulf of Mexico
it became known as the Carnival Cruise
monster
and the description sounded a lot like a
long extinct apex predator
the mosasaur
but if the Mosasaur had survived the
extinction event which killed off three
quarters of the plant and animal species
on Earth then we definitely know about
it
it would have completely changed what
our oceans look like and how we use them
in fact if the Mosasaur was still
roaming our oceans the Megalodon might
never have existed
but how can one animal have such a huge
impact
these nightmarish marine animals were
actually giant lizards kind of like the
land-dwelling Komodo dragons but they
evolved for life in the ocean
their Anatomy made them dangerous
predators imagine a lizard monster with
the double hinged jaw of a snake massive
teeth and a tail like a shark
oh and they could be as large as 18
meters long
that's four meters longer than your
average yellow school bus
they basically ate anything they wanted
no fish dolphins sharks whales or even
other mosasaurs were safe
fossils from this species have been
found on every continent including
Antarctica
evidence that these lizard Kings
dominated the oceans in the Cretaceous
Period but they weren't also ferocious
with some species being as small as one
meter long
then how did they become so terrifying
their ancestors were more like the
marine iguanas living on the Galapagos
Islands today around 90 million years
ago these lizards would have ventured
into the ocean for food
at first they stayed close to the
Shoreline but as they evolved they
started to make the open ocean their
home
the evolution of their powerful tail
vertebrae made them skilled and Speedy
swimmers helping them move further away
from the shore but they also remained
close to the surface because like
dolphins and whales they needed to come
up for air it only took 27 million years
for the Mosasaur of Jurassic Park to
evolve of course the Mosasaur in this
movie is not very accurate even though a
real Mosasaur was smaller than the one
in Jurassic Park it was still a very
dangerous Creature if this species were
alive today it would completely alter
our oceans but why would it change them
and how would it affect the way we use
our oceans much of the marine life we
know today probably wouldn't exist with
the Mosasaur inhabiting our seas they
just wouldn't have stood a chance
against this Mighty foe instead the fish
and mammals in our oceans would look and
act much differently than they do today
they would have adapted special traits
and methods to avoid the mosasaurus one
ecological theory is that Predators
actually drive Evolution because they
force prey to adapt and quickly in fact
a 2007 study found that the diversity of
marine creatures over the past hundreds
of millions of years is directly tied to
interactions between predator and prey
so our oceans might actually be even
more diverse if the mosasaurus still
existed but what about us well this
giant lizard would make the oceans a
much more dangerous place for humans
we would need much larger boats
small fishing boats and sailboats could
be swallowed whole by this creature
ocean Hobbies like sailing and fishing
wouldn't be as popular and swimming and
surfing would certainly be
life-threatening and maybe the story of
Moby Dick would be about a menacing
Mosasaur instead of a whale
thankfully mosasaurs do not exist today
or our oceans would look completely
different and that's a good thing
Tyrannosaurus Rex
now the Tyrant lizards
it's sick meters tall
12 meters long and it weighs upward of
seven tons
you can hide from it you might even be
able to outrun it
but do you really want to do this every
day
what would it be like to live with T-Rex
would we keep them in zoos
would we eat them in restaurants
would we wear them on our backs
or would we live in constant fear of
being chomped clawed or trampled
this is what if and here's what would
happen if T-Rex were still alive
roughly 66 million years ago a massive
asteroid thought to be about 15
kilometers wide
hit the Earth with an impact equal to
several million nuclear bombs detonating
at once
this triggered the sudden mass
extinction of approximately 75 percent
of all plant and animal species on the
planet
among them was the most powerful
terrestrial Predator to have ever lived
the Tyrannosaurus Rex
as one of the most popular prehistoric
animals being able to see a T-Rex in the
flesh is a pretty common fantasy
but what if we got what we wished for
and T-Rex were still alive today
would Humanity be able to survive
alongside them
were T-Rex as vicious and as ruthless as
they appear to be in movies and TV
or with these massive dinosaurs be more
worried about us than we'd be of them
if T-Rex were alive today chances are
they'd be an endangered species
they're terrifying reputation would be
no match for the habitat loss pollution
and food shortages caused by humans
because of this T-Rex populations would
be a lot smaller and it's even possible
that they would have evolved to be a
smaller size
we'd probably have to keep them in
sanctuaries similar to a wildlife safari
since letting them roam freely would be
bad for both T-Rex and humans
in the wild a T-Rex would have to look
out for hunters or poachers who'd want
the thrill and the bragging rights of
taking down a seven ton Beast
but even if you were smart enough to
keep your distance a hungry T-Rex
looking for food might find itself
stumbling onto a farm or breaking into a
City Zoo
and if you can't imagine a rampaging
T-Rex storming around your city just
imagine an upright bus with two legs and
sharp teeth that have a maximum bite
force of about 5 800 kilograms
but it's not like T-Rex would always be
out hunting humans
scientific evidence suggests that T-Rex
might have been more like scavengers
than predators
unlike most predators that tend to have
super sharp vision
T-Rex's eyes were small and weak
this dinosaur also had unusually Small
Arms compared to the rest of their body
which wouldn't have been very effective
for fighting prey
however T-Rex did have unusually large
olfactory lobes as part of their brains
which scientists think would have been
helpful for smelling rotting carcasses
from far away
but that same powerful sense of smell
might also draw T-Rex to Country ranches
or Urban meat factories which would
almost certainly end in disaster a T-Rex
could eat up to 230 kilograms of meat in
just one bite
so your farm animals wouldn't last very
long
and if you wanted to defend them or
simply prevent your house from being
crushed
you wouldn't be able to take on a T-Rex
without a gun and if you didn't have one
you'd have to run for your life
some racks weren't super fast Runners
with some scientists believing their top
speed was around 16 kilometers an hour
so if you ran and hid in a dense forest
where it would be hard for them to
maneuver you might be safe
you could also try to trip the T-Rex
that's chasing you since they're top
heavy dinosaurs that had a hard time
getting up if they fell
of course we wouldn't have to worry
about endangered livestock and
outsmarting T-Rex if we kept them safely
confined to Wildlife preserves
we could create large habitats for them
and grow food to feed them
so that their appetites wouldn't get
them or us into trouble the sanctuaries
probably wouldn't look like anything
from Jurassic Park since well we've seen
how well that worked
but maybe with enough space food and
under proper management
humans could co-exist with T-Rex how
cool would it be to see a real-life
T-Rex if only that one fatal asteroid
never hit the Earth
would dinosaurs still be alive today
would they have evolved would humans
have survived this long
could we ever learn to co-exist this is
what if and here's what would happen if
dinosaurs never went extinct
until 66 million years ago dinosaurs of
all shapes and sizes roamed the Earth
intelligent adaptable and sometimes
weighing as much as two jet planes it's
hard to believe that it only took one
rock to wipe them all out
of course this was no ordinary Rock
the asteroid that took out the dinosaurs
was nine miles wide and hit Earth with
the destructive force of 10 billion
Hiroshima bombs
the radioactive Shockwave obliterated
everything for hundreds of miles in
every direction and 75 percent of all
species on Earth went extinct
if that asteroid had hit just a little
earlier a little later or even a few
miles off course we would be living in a
very different world today
the rock that killed the dinosaurs
struck the shallow Waters of Mexico's
Yucatan Peninsula had it landed a little
farther off the coast in a deeper part
of the ocean the water might have
absorbed some of the blast along with
its devastating effects on the
atmosphere but even if the asteroid
missed the Earth dinosaurs would have to
survive several significant Global
events in order to make it to the
present day 55 million years ago
temperatures Rose the climate was eight
degrees hotter than it is today
rainforest sprouted and vegetation
flourished herbivores would have adapted
and thrived but they'd have started to
look a little different the plants of
this period were less nutritious and
easier to digest meaning dinosaurs would
likely shrink in size since their new
diet wouldn't have as much energy
roughly 20 million years after that
South America and Antarctica split
creating a cooler and drier world
climate during this period long-legged
fast-moving dinosaurs would have evolved
to travel the huge grasslands stretching
out across the globe
compared to mammals of this period
dinosaurs held significant advantages
such as having more teeth and better
eyesight considering the dinosaurs were
already so Advanced scientists wonder
whether mammals would have evolved at
all if dinosaurs hadn't gone extinct
it's likely that the big animals we know
today would have been prey to dinosaurs
but remember humans evolved alongside
woolly mammoths and saber-toothed cats
while those species didn't survive the
ice ages of 2.6 million years ago given
the evolutionary traits of some
dinosaurs there's a chance they might
have persisted
but what about us
could we handle freezing temperatures
and huge terrifyingly vicious predators
they say running keeps the body warm but
that might also make you taste better
in an alternate universe if we did
survive alongside these Prehistoric
Beasts it's possible we could see a real
live T-Rex on a protected Reserve not
unlike Jurassic Park
human population growth and excessive
hunting would have driven larger
dinosaurs to near Extinction today they
would most certainly be an endangered
species but those that shrank and
adapted over millions of years could
coexist peacefully Among Us
fact some actually do
where do you think pigeons came from
it's hard to believe the birds were once
the size of biplanes but then again it's
hard to believe that with a slight twist
of fate we might have walked with
Dinosaurs or we might have become
dinosaur chow and not have evolved at
all
[Music]
roughly 60 million years ago
the largest snake to ever exist roamed
the Earth
this is the Titanoboa
this giant snake hunted reptiles birds
and even crocodiles
so what would happen if this creature
roamed the Earth today
how much food would it need to eat
would it be a threat to humans
and how big was this thing
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Titanoboa never went
extinct
discovered in Colombia its official name
is the Titanoboa cerejonasis
with a length of 15 meters and weighing
just over 1 000 kilograms it would be
almost three times the size of a giant
anaconda if you're a person of average
height
it's one meter girth would be as high as
your waist
fortunately or maybe unfortunately you'd
be most likely to find a titanoboa when
you're both hunting for fish or swimming
it's a matter of physics
moving around in the water is much
easier for creatures like huge whales
and this snake rather than being on land
and although living in trees has never
been an option for this great snake it
could Trek Inland on occasion
scientists are speculating that it
belongs to the snake family called boys
they're non-venomous snakes which sounds
pretty safe but titanoboas might use
teeth to grab a hold of their prey
and it's been said that the teeth can
bend like curved hooks sticking into you
the more the prey struggles the more it
gets hooked
then they squeeze their prey
after a few minutes ischemia happens
blood flow to the heart or brain is
restricted causing a shortage of oxygen
and eventually death
fossils show that a titanoboa's lower
jaw extends past the back of the skull
giving it a greater range of movement
when opening its mouth it could swallow
you in one piece
titanoboa probably fed on giant turtles
and primitive crocodiles which were
about six meters in length
a snake this size would probably have to
eat about 40 kilograms of food every day
that's twice as much as an anaconda
these snakes are killers that can move
easily in water humans might be an ideal
snack
places such as Australia seem to coexist
with dangerous snakes but the sheer
massiveness of a titanoboa would dwarf
anything we're used to
titanoboas would prefer a hot damp
jungle-like area like the Amazon
snakes rely on heat from outside their
bodies to survive
about 58 million years ago
titanoboas lived in an environment about
five degrees warmer than it is today
maybe we'd find these giant snakes in
Asia or what about a place like Florida
it's sweltering and humid for part of
the year
because of its massive body roughly the
size of a small car it would most likely
hide in hot swampy areas or lakes
this allows it to hunt more efficiently
alligators lounging along Golf Course
Lakes are common in Florida and the
Titanoboa could easily be attracted to
this food Haven
and if there are no alligators on the
menu that day what would be the next
best option yeah golfers
I bet you're wondering if there's any
benefit to having titanoboa around well
yeah Pest Control
raccoons deer or anything ripping
through your garbage would no longer be
an issue with a titanoboa on the lookout
now although the Titanoboa is extinct we
recommend that you stay clear of giant
snakes
[Music]
and this giant scary Predator is setting
its hungry sights on you
what would running into this dinosaur be
like
how could you possibly Escape
and what would happen if it sunk its
teeth into you
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you were attacked by a T-Rex
during the late Cretaceous Period about
66 million years ago the T-Rex was one
of the largest known meat-eating
dinosaurs
its full name Tyrannosaurus Rex means
king of the Tyrant lizards and it
certainly fits the profile
these dinosaurs towered at up to six
meters tall
with the strongest bite of any land
animal that ever lived the T-Rex was a
ferocious predator
back in its day it was roaming the once
Lush and warm western parts of the
United States
but somehow it's back and it's on the
hunt for you run
your peaceful walk in the park would
take a turn for the worse
you'd look up and suddenly see the
frightening sight of a T-Rex Rising
above you
Frozen with fear you'd quickly take in
its terrifying features its powerful
tail counterbalancing a massive skull
it's thick neck muscles and its muscular
thighs that would be a good reminder
that you shouldn't have skipped your leg
day at the gym
though I wouldn't advise it you might
involuntarily chuckle at the sight of
the dinosaur's puny two-fingered
forearms
but your amusement wouldn't last long
the T-Rex would flash its gigantic teeth
at you some of those could be 30
centimeters long
as a fan of the Jurassic Park film
franchise you might think that the best
thing to do is remain standing as still
as possible but research suggests that
the T-Rex had a sense of vision as good
or better than modern day Eagles
yeah now would be a good time to run
another thing Jurassic Park LED you to
believe is that in order to get away
from this Predator you'd need to be able
to move as fast as a car well that would
mean running at a speed of 50 kilometers
per hour and that's impossible for
humans
yeah even the world's fastest person
Usain Bolt with his top speed of 44
kilometers per hour wouldn't make it out
alive
but you'd still have a chance today
scientists debate whether or not the
T-Rex could run at all
research supporting the theory that the
dyno could run estimates that this
Predator would be able to move at a
moderate pace of about 25 to 40
kilometers per hour any faster and it
would break its legs
on the other hand
not have been able to run at all
walked at a slower than human pace of
five kilometers per hour that's about as
fast as a soft shell turtle
knowing this you could jog a comfortable
distance from the attacking T-Rex then
if you're not a runner soon enough you'd
stop to catch a breath but that would be
a mistake
your moment of relaxation would suddenly
be interrupted by extremely sharp pain
yeah another T-Rex has found you with
its amazing sense of smell and it would
sink its teeth into you
with that sharp pain you'd feel your
bones being crushed
the T-Rex would be using its so-called
puncture and pull strategy on you
the dinosaur would drag its teeth right
through your Flesh and Bones
this would be a gruesome way to die
its front teeth would grip and pull you
to shreds while its side teeth tear your
flesh from your body its back teeth
would be moving your body closer and
closer to the T-Rex's throat
struggling to break free wouldn't help
you now your attacker's wide teeth
wouldn't break from your wiggling after
all this Dino used to hunt triceratops
and to make things worse the dinosaur's
powerful neck muscles would thrash you
around
these muscles would be strong enough to
throw a 50 kilogram chunk of meat about
five meters into the air
hey sorry to be so gruesome but what did
you think running into a prehistoric
creature like this would be like
[Music]
with the world's population growing
every year we need to find ways to
produce more food
so if we could bring dinosaurs back from
the dead would you eat them
how can we bring dinosaurs back from
Extinction
how much would they need to eat each day
and which dinosaur would be the most
delicious
we're sparing no expense things are
becoming Jurassic
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we raised dinosaurs for food
dinosaurs haven't walked the Earth for
65 million years
but if we managed to bring them back
could we raise them for food and eat
their meat
just like the movie Jurassic Park we
could possibly bring back dinosaurs
did you know that dinosaur DNA is most
closely related to chicken DNA
but unlike in the movies it wouldn't be
easy to bring dinos back we would need
to have some dino DNA that hasn't
deteriorated and unfortunately that
isn't easy to come by
but let's say we did stumble upon some
suitable dinosaur DNA
what would be the next steps
well scientists have been trying to
resurrect woolly mammoths by sequencing
their DNA from a frozen specimen
then they synthesized its genes and
placed them into an Asian elephant
embryo as 99 of their genomes are
similar we could do the same thing to
bring back dinosaurs but we'd use a
chicken egg instead
then we'd leave it under a heater and
see if a dinosaur hatches
if it were a dinosaur we'd treat it just
like other farm animals we race
and we'd need to feed that hungry
dinosaur baby
so how much would a dinosaur need to eat
well if you've watched Jurassic Park you
know that dinosaurs come in a range of
shapes and sizes
so it depends on what the dinosaur's
diet is
for instance herbivores like the
Brachiosaurus could weigh four kilograms
at Birth and within a few months they
could easily wait 10 times more
once it becomes an adult this
plant-eating giant would weigh in at a
whopping 35 to 56 metric tons
that's about the same as 120 head of
cattle
and it would need to eat 400 kilograms
of food per day that's how much 16 dairy
cows eat in a day
but let's not forget how much meat that
dinosaur would give you
'd have quite a feast
and speaking of meat which dinosaur do
you think would taste best
well it's hard to know because no one
alive today has ever tried dinosaur meat
but if we compare it to the meats we
enjoy the most delicious tend to be from
herbivores the plant-eating animals like
our Brachiosaurus
something like the infamous T-Rex might
taste a little different
we know that dinosaurs are distant
relatives of birds and fast-moving
dinosaurs would mainly consist of white
meat so a T-Rex might taste like an
ostrich
maybe you'd prefer to eat seafood well
in that case you might want to try
eating dinosaurs that had Marine diets
they might have a fishier flavor
and here's one thing you probably hadn't
even thought of
recent Studies have shown that dinosaurs
like T-Rex had feathers
so if we did raise them for food imagine
plucking a dinosaur that big
one Tyrannosaur fossil had feathers that
measured an incredible one meter long
so it would be a little different than
plucking a chicken
but before we get too carried away we'd
better say that bringing back dinosaurs
is not very likely
and if we were to do it there would be
other consequences and maybe some that
we couldn't handle
just like in Jurassic Park things could
get out of hand pretty quickly
but if you think about it we're already
eating dinosaurs or at least they're
very distant relative the chicken
they might be smaller but they sure
taste good
why are these crocodiles spending so
much time on dry land
is it because their watery homes are too
polluted
or is it because they're scared of a
bigger Predator lurking in the water
an ancient dinosaur that we thought was
long gone but it never left
meet the spinosaurus it's more massive
than the Tyrannosaurus Rex likes to swim
and loves to eat anything that enters
its territory
if humans had been living alongside
these River Monsters all along
how different would our lives have been
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the spinosaurus never went
extinct
[Music]
the spinosaurus lived about 95 million
years ago with a body length of 14 to 18
meters
and an estimated mass of 12 000 to 20
000 kilograms
it was the largest Predator the Nile has
ever seen
if it had somehow managed to avoid the
extinction of the dinosaurs it would
still be swimming there
and Egypt would have never developed to
be what it is today
would ancient Egyptians still have been
able to rely on the Nile River for food
and transportation
would they have found a way to coexist
with the giant River Monsters
or would they have fought them to the
death
the spinosaurus had a long tail that
produced a higher thrust and was more
efficient in the water than the tail
shapes of other dinosaurs this made them
very hard to escape from in the water
but they were not as threatening on land
because they were pretty clumsy and not
well adapted to it
so if we lived in a world where the
spinosaurus still existed then all we'd
have to do is stay out of their water
and we'd be safe right
not exactly we wouldn't be the only ones
to fear these giant dinosaurs
today lots of crocodiles live along the
Nile River if the spinosaurus had
survived the mass extinction and still
lived in the Nile today the crocodiles
would be looking for a new home on land
and if crocodiles became land dwellers
the land along the Nile would look very
different too
crocodiles might eat small mammals and
humans would need to be more aware of
their surroundings to protect themselves
from the crocodiles
as bad as an increase in crocodile
encounter sounds it wouldn't be the most
significant change we'd experience in a
world with Spinosaurus
Egypt's history and social Evolution
could have been very different
ancient Egyptian culture relied on the
Nile River and if this large
semi-aquatic dinosaur was roaming around
they might not have been able to use it
as much or at least they would have
needed a way to protect themselves from
the giant dinosaur
hunting the spinosaurus wouldn't have
been easy but it would have been
necessary if Northern African
communities wanted a steady supply of
fish to eat
the practice would have become so
important to the people's survival that
hieroglyphics would probably have had
drawings of the dinosaur and how the
Egyptians captured and killed them
over the years in true human form we
would probably have started hunting the
spinosaurus for sport and fashion
you think crocodile boots are cool wait
until you see Spinosaurus sandals
maybe we would even have hunted them so
much that they'd be on the brink of
Extinction and what then would they
become a protected species or would we
all be happy to see them disappear
well before you go making save the
spinosaurus signs just remember that
none of this is really likely to have
happened
the spinosaurus probably died from the
mass extinction event that wiped out the
dinosaurs if it didn't it would have
quickly gone extinct soon after because
of the lack of food
there would have been massive
competition for food between spinosaurs
since the environment was more favorable
for small creatures that didn't need as
much food
[Music]
but that's probably a good thing
even if it might have been cool to live
with Dinosaurs if these huge dinosaurs
were still living they would have
changed evolution in Africa
we might have had different fish land
animals and ancient civilizations that
were adapted for living alongside these
massive creatures
it's the matchup you've been waiting for
the clash between some of the biggest
Titans that ever roamed the Earth
today we're going back in time to see
two terrifying predators
from the jungle Marsh to the deep ocean
you can expect a Megalodon titanoboa
fight to be an epic brawl that will go
down in history
how could this Mega Snake overpower the
mega shark
what superpower would give the shark an
advantage
and which animal would Tower over the
other
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a Megalodon fought a Titanoboa
okay before the Carnage begins let's
break down the stats on these Fighters
the Megalodon is one of the largest
predators that ever lived
these sharks hunted in the oceans 20
million years ago but they went extinct
3.6 million years ago
growing to a length of 18 meters these
beasts measured three times longer than
the largest great white shark ever
recorded
and check out this massive jaw spanning
three meters wide with
276 teeth inside
that jaw is strong enough to crush a car
but will this killer meet its match
against the Fearsome Titanoboa
in this corner lies a prehistoric snake
that could haunt your dreams the
Titanoboa
this serpent lived during the paleocene
epoch which ended 56 million years ago
After The Dinosaurs went extinct
titanoboa became the top predator
slithering around on land
measuring an average of 13 meters and
weighing about one and a quarter tons
this snake could roam unchallenged
it dominated its Terrain but a new
Challenger has entered
while this snake was known to devour
giant turtles fish and reptiles the
Megalodon might just take a bite out of
the Titanoboa
so let's get down to the main event the
only reason you clicked play
this prehistoric Grudge Match has been
millions of years in the making
but where could these Giants duke it out
they both thrived in warmer climates but
the Megalodon lives in the ocean and
titanoboa slides through the jungles
you'd have to lure the shark into
mangroves or an estuary where the fresh
water meets the sea
the Megalodons amazing sense of smell
might detect the giant snake first
or it could use its incredible
superpower
some sharks have electroreceptors that
detect electrical Fields the energy that
their prey generates
this ability could allow the Meg to
strike first
but this Serpentine Predator has a few
tricks of its own
titanoboa stocked its prey by hiding in
water or between trees and waiting for
the perfect moment to strike which might
take days
if the Megalodon swims right under the
snake the Titanoboa could attack before
the shark knows what hit it if the snake
dives into the water it could sink its
curved teeth into the shark and as the
Megalodon thrashes around those meat
hooks would dig deeper and deeper into
the shark's flesh the serpent would coil
itself tightly around its prey and
squeeze hard trying to choke the life
out of the Megalodon
with over
276 kilopascals of pressure the
Titanoboa could really put the squeeze
on the Megalodon
but sharks don't have lungs they have
gills that absorb oxygen from the water
and while that massive snake's jaw opens
1.8 meters wide it's not enough to
swallow this aquatic Beast hole
titanoboa needs to crush the Megalodon
and collapse its organs or block its
Gill openings if the snake can drag the
shark into shallow water this fight is
over but in deeper waters the Megalodon
could use a high-speed assault and
attack from underneath
the Furious shark would use its jaws of
death to maim and disable the snake
violently shaking the titanoboa's body
in moments those razor-sharp teeth would
split the snake in two
the battle between these two Titans
would depend on which Contender Finds
Its opponent first
it would be a test of patience and
Savage strength between Giants who are
anything but sluggish or slow
but since these monsters didn't live at
the same time well we'll never know for
sure how this match would have gone down
but what if you witnessed a fight
between a Megalodon and its ancient
rival the Leviathan whale
well keep watching because that's a
story for another
what if
[Music]
an ancient creature is lurking in the
ocean
it's double the size of a T-Rex
it's gigantic Jaws could crush a car and
now it's on the hunt for you
Megalodon sharks haven't existed for
more than 2 million years